so who do you like out of this group you
know I I met you a couple weeks ago that
the in the spin room at the GOP debate
and I was able to ask Scott Walker a
question and I asked about campaign
finance and I got to tell you sometimes
you look at someone and you go this
guy's dumb I mean he he struck me as
dumb he just I could he I could just see
it you know you mean like I could just
look in him and see this is not a bright
guy now you don't have to comment on
that specific not dumb look he's won a
lot of elections he won more anyway
those guys what do you think of the
general the general crap I think the
general crop overall is a very strong
group of individuals you look at the
governor's the governor's that are in
the race who were in the race you look
at the Senators Carly Fiorina a very
successful businesswoman Carly Ben
Carson very successful neurosurgeon so
it's a it's a diverse group it is the
most diverse field we put up ever not
just in terms of a woman in African
America and all that but just in terms
of background and experience the depth
of it I mean George Jeb Bush was a very
successful did a good job as governor
and in Florida elected strongly two
times John Kasich same thing in Ohio I
went through hell in the first term and
weathered that storm what did you make a
k-6 answer to the to the gay marriage
question in the first that was a that
was a beautiful thing great that was for
me that was an authentically Republican
response that's that that in Jeb Bush
when he talked about immigration again
an authentically Republican response
because at the end of the day what Jeb
was saying and he used the language that
people could understand he didn't commit
it in policy and political ease he used
the word love which to me and to a whole
lot of people was a recognition of
people behind the policy mm-hmm that
while you can sit back and talk all this
smack about you know we're gonna build
walls and we're gonna Electrify them or
we're gonna do all this crap at the end
of the day there Pete
behind that and if you don't appreciate
that then you don't have a good policy
it's not it's not a smart policy and I
think that that was something my
takeaway in his discussion which I
thought was a very humble and a very
personal way to talk about immigration
no one ever talked about it on either
side in those terms and and I thought he
did well by that so in a way you kind of
want to combine these guys if you could
combine a couple of the issues well you
know Rankin Stein yeah I mean well we're
doing pretty good on the Frankenstein
part without the combination the I I
think no I think that they're in a real
sense you're right I mean it what I'm
looking for at the end of that I like
John Kasich I like Jeb I mean I like a
lot of these guys but what I'm looking
for and I've said this from the very
beginning of the cycle I'm looking for
someone who's prepared to sacrifice
their race for the presidency that's
what it's gonna take
yeah in other words and Jeb got close he
used the words when he said I'm willing
to lose the primary to win the general
but really sit there and go you know
what America this is it
let's just cut the crap you want too
much and we can't deliver that's how the
conversation starts because it gets you
into spending it gets you into programs
it gets you into the size of government
it gets you into policy it gets you into
everything though you know we are our
own worst enemies as Americans because
what do we say folks we say cut spending
less government well I want more in my
paycheck and then in the next sentence
why don't you put more money in that
program why aren't you spending more on
this right why aren't you giving to this
cause over here what do you want so the
question for me is always boiled down
very simply and you know the model you
did a little economics of school right
not well you know you know the whole
idea of guns and butter yeah all right
it was always you you can either have
guns or you can have butter well I think
there's a different model well you can
actually have both but the only way you
get to have both is by prioritizing
because in any given moment at any given
time
something is going to be the priority so
that's what we focus on let's address
that so that means we're going to spend
a little bit less on guns today and more
on butter because we need to put people
back to work we need to make sure that
hospitals stay open we make sure that oh
gee that bridge is falling down we need
to fix it all right that's the priority
so we put a little bit more into that at
another time the priorities may shift
okay whether it's something that happens
overseas Isis gets stupid more stupid
than they already are whatever and
you've got to deal with that then maybe
we spend a little bit less we
reprioritize and we don't do that the
second thing is government gets out and
it says look we're going to impose these
restrictions we're going to make you do
this and we're going to give you all
this stuff
all right fine I'm happy with that great
right people like stuff people like
stuff yeah but no one ever goes back to
see or find out how the stuff is working
and whether or not the program that
you've designed No Child Left Behind
actually works for teachers in the
classroom or whether you know the the
institution that you've created our
social safety net in all of its various
forms actually meets the needs of the
people who's supposed to be treated I'm
thinking right now the VA so again
making government accountable for all of
that is important but also the role that
we play in that process is equally
important because what's happened down
is our politicians you're telling them
every different thing and so if you
comment this way you come at this where
you come it this way what happens they
just standstill right and they do
nothing and then they don't they're not
governed by a basic set of principles
they talked about earlier so they're
going everywhere so they're going every
which way and they've given everybody
anything and they've just said mega well
that's what you want and I'm done yeah
all right that's not what we want
ultimately we are actually looking for
someone to take the risk which is the
bottom line point are you prepared to
take the risk to do the job so when I
was lieutenant governor my approach to
being a lieutenant governor was I only
have four years to do this job because
the other four aren't guaranteed and
they weren't because I didn't but I
walked out having reformed a minority
business enterprise got charter school
passed in the state and worked on a
number of initiatives including the
death penalty that the governor asked me
to work on and I felt that we had done
the job that people have sent us to do
now the politics took over in that case
and that's the risk you know the
governor of Maryland that my buddy Bob
Ehrlich got fired with a 62% job
approval on election day but you know
people hate it Republicans in 2006
because of the war and a lot of other
things so but you do the job you can't
think about the next election and right
now politicians are more concerned about
being primary or losing an election and
they don't do the job yeah so that's
really where I want to go with this but
do you want the 30 seconds to do Trump
or should we just tell we get to Trump
by 30 seconds go what do you make this
thing Trump is an enigma wrapped in a
question mark wrapped in I mean he's a
lot in a wig wrapped in a wig
he's all these things he's all these
things that have upset the status quo of
American politics everybody is everybody
wants to run a conventional campaign
except Trump he's running an
unconventional campaign everybody else
is running a conventional campaign in an
unconventional time and they don't know
how to do what deal with it or what to
do with it and he is you know whether or
not he gets the nomination all of that
remains to be seen folks we're a long
way from the first vote being cast
Keightley we're over a year away from
the election there's no we're actually
well no but we're actually only three
months away from the first primary
caucus votes and that's where that's
where the the real rubber begins to meet
the road
that's when voters actually have to go
into a caucus room like this or in a
voting booth and actually think about
who where they're going to give this
next charge to to be the president and I
think that dynamic as you get through
this third debate and the fourth debate
in December and then in the January
we'll begin to settle but Trump has
changed the way we do this and I think
that's good I appreciate it you know I
talked to people all across the country
they don't like what he's
about Mexicans they don't like the way
he talks about women they don't like a
lot about Trump but you know every
sentence that starts like that the next
word is but I don't like what he said
but yeah I don't appreciate that but and
I keep telling folks in DC as long as
they're saying but then anything can
happen anything can happen so is that
the interesting thing about about both
parties right now because Trump and
Bernie to me are hitting on the same
thing which is that the system is broke
I mean in the first debate Trump
basically said he said yeah I gave
Hillary a lot of money and she showed up
at my wedding because that's how
politicians operate right and he's
telling the truth outside so you have
the capitalist right the poster child
for capitalism social and and the poster
child for socialism and those are the
two that are getting away so what are
you making oh there's your ticket make
sure that yeah that's it
Sanders versus Trump 2016 yeah I want to
be at that part I'm gonna have myself a
gin and tonic and a popcorn yeah
can you imagine I mean really like in
the debate if it was the two of them cuz
cuz Bernie oh my clearly unfiltered
Trump's off his rocker I mean it would
be something right wait a minute so why
is Bernie unfiltered and Trump off his
rocker because Bernie because we think
is apologize why can't Bernie why can't
Trump be unfiltered - well no Trump is
unfiltered but there's one ether filter
all right well just say - tell that to
all the people are following them I've
been trying to tell but see but you're
not listening what see but but you're
actually making the the more important
point that folks keep missing it's that
and I'm not vote for you I'll bring it
raised attitude is that attitude that's
pissing everybody off you think you know
better than the person who's following
him and that's that's just not or that
that's just not right you've got to
respect that that's where our policies
has gotten - we've stopped respecting
the fact that I can follow you because I
actually like what you're saying even
though you think he's full of [ __ ]
excuse me right so I love listen but but
but that's but that's but that's that's
the American process
that you don't get to judge it I'm
winning if you do know you think don't
judge it out loud because then I may hit
you fair enough so I'm sorry what I'm
saying so I'm with you on that but to me
Trump this isn't a real Candace I just
don't think why do you say that we'll
revisit this in gonna know he has filed
the paperwork
yeah he's disclosed his income he's got
a campaign organization
trust me this brother's got a campaign
organization in a number of states that
people don't even know he's got a
campaign organization in he's doing the
things look you know what was a telling
moment I don't know if how many of you
caught it remember when he rolled out
his economic plan yep
what did you notice about what he did
anybody it's everything second on power
yeah he had no cards yes he was able to
read off the top of his head he read off
a prepared text Trump is in this thing
the right way everything he's done up to
now has gotten your attention and now
he's rolling out a little policy on this
a little policy I'm telling you watch it
because the attitude of the folks in
Washington about his campaign is the the
thing that keeps him in the campaign I
get that I mean I do get oh you hate
hearing that but no all right so well I
can I can hear something and be yeah
look Huffington Post says they're not
gonna write about him in the politics
session and right that gets that gets
the base the base angry all right sorry
that was the longest 30 seconds I know
it drove right